fences is directed by Denzel Washington
starring him and Viola Davis and is the
story of a married couple trying to
raise a family in the 1950s and all the
struggles that come with doing that this
is written by August Wilson based off of
his play and a lot of people deemed this
unfilmable because it's just a lot of
really long dialogue sequences featuring
people in the middle of arguments or
joking or singing or telling stories and
so people are like well we can't turn
this into a movie because who's gonna
want to watch that you know a bunch of
talking oh I don't know people who liked
Glengarry Glen Ross another great film
that was a play that was turned into a
film or Roman Polanski's carnage I mean
it happens people it's it's not that
strange I always find it so funny when
people say that certain things are
unfilmable I mean some of the best
movies of all time feature extremely
long dialogue sequences set in one or
two locations there are three specific
reasons you should see this film the
script by August Wilson
Viola Davis and Denzel Washington this
is some of the best acting I've seen all
year and these sequences that are so
long and drawn-out where people start
and you're like okay this is a nice
little conversation you're smiling
you're laughing with them and then
someone just says something maybe just
the wrong thing perhaps denzel's son
looks at him in the wrong way and he
just snaps and turns into a disgusting
human being Denzel Washington's
character in this movie is very complex
he starts out he's a likeable guy
he holds a job he's trying to support
his family you feel like this is just a
good old-fashioned man trying to provide
for his family put a roof over their
heads put food on the table and you
relate to him in that way and then all
of a sudden throughout the film you get
these subtle hints that he's not the
greatest person that he has a lot of
flaws you learn a little bit about his
backstory how he was raised and then you
see some serious go down in his
family and it is heart-wrenching the
acting in this film is so powerful it
really does transcend the film
experience and it does feel like a play
just edited together as a film and I
love that about this movie I love
watching these actors have so much
breathing room to
form and the performances absolutely
shine Denzel and Viola Davis in
particular are both oscar-worthy in this
movie they are brilliant they're both
giving really big loud performances and
you could look at that and say well
they're really trying for that Oscar but
when you really think about the
experiences that they are dealing with
in their family I can't see it happening
any other way in real life there's gonna
be loud scenes there's gonna be
explosions there's gonna be these big
dramatic moments because if some of the
things that happen in this movie
happened to a real family that's how it
would go down and it's so well portrayed
that there were many moments throughout
this movie where I actually forgot I was
watching a movie and that is so so rare
denzel's made two other films before
Antwone Fisher and the Great Debaters
he's actually shown himself to be a
really good director no one really talks
about that too much because he doesn't
do it that often but whenever he gets
his hands on a project I'm always
interested to see what he's going to do
and I think this might actually be the
best film he's honed as for issues with
fences there's one moment towards the
end of this film that really betrays the
rest of it it gets really cheesy and
fake and I just didn't believe it for a
second other than that this is an
excellent film with amazing performances
and I'm going to give fences and a -
it's in theaters now if you want to have
a heart wrenching gut-wrenching
Christmas at the theater go check it out
it has amazing work from a lot of really
talented actors guys thank you so much
for watching my reviews in the year of
2016 this is going to be my final review
of the year I still have my best and
worst of the year videos coming to you
very very soon I can't wait to do that
you guys are the best thank you so much
for watching and if you like this you
can click right here and get stuck mine
eyes
[Applause]
[Music]